[Music]
more than 20 years ago Ron Haskins and
Isabel Sawhill at the Brookings
Institution sifted the social science
data and found that anyone who finishes
high school works full-time and marries
before having children almost never
experiences poverty they called this the
success sequence but the sequence misses
is that each of these steps is enormous
ly complex it takes a lot of parental
attention energy and love before a child
crosses the stage at a high school
graduation social networks are critical
to finding a full-time job a happy
marriage is arguably the most complex
challenge of all looked at this way it's
not so much a sequence as a decade's
long dialogue between the individual
their family and friends and the
community education work and marriage
are the marks of a successful life as it
unfolds weeoo Haskins and soft Hill at
profound thanks for bringing us the
success sequence the job now is
developing the strategies for
strengthening families and communities
so that more people find the path and
stay on them what do you think are the
most important factors in success and
how can we work together to make the
promise of America or reality for more
people let us know in your comments also
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds and
be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
researching videos from AEI